but yeah all under the great job I
didn't have a belly Hat person she was
did a great job of getting open catching
the ball touchdown of what it's all
about
not bad for a running back indeed Laura
that's right Bill Polian said he should
play receiver nobody shouldn't he should
play quarterback and and look the the
Dolphins
sold out to stop the run they watched
the film from last year you shouldn't
watch the film from last year unless you
wanted to lose which is the separate and
very important issue that the Dolphins
are now dealing with I was told in the
aftermath of the game that multiple
players already saying get me out of
here to their agents get me traded they
sense what's going on it's no secret
look I know Brian floor as a head coach
of the team has said all the right
things you can't come out and say we're
trying to lose games you would be find
into oblivion by the league office you'd
be suspended you'd lose draft picks they
don't want anything to undermine the
integrity of the game right and
acknowledging that you're losing games
now in the hopes of winning games later
would be the quickest way to do it
but I know that that's the plan the plan
is tear it down build it up sometimes
you got to just take your lumps right
that is the t-shirt slogan for the
Dolphins this year and the players are
smart enough to figure it out court and
they don't want to be part of it Chris
no I mean it the sports too tough and
too brutal to for players sometimes to
want to be a part of scenarios like this
especially guys who were let's say six
years and above in the NFL cuz they're
just going mad I don't know how many
years I got left in this league and I'm
a part of a team that's really not
trying to win right now it's all about
the future and yeah players have a hard
time swallowing that but this is part of
being a professional - I'll say to those
players and this is why you're getting a
good paycheck on a weekly basis I know
it's not easy I know it stinks but it's
just the reality of the situation and
it's not like they're going out trying
to lose on Sunday right no no the team
is being set up built roster wise where
it yes it's just not gonna win many
Sunday's cuz there they are in the
rebuild process but but I'm told that
the players are starting to sense that
the coaches really aren't trying they
really that they're that they kind of
understand what the mandate is and you
know that that's that's where it's gonna
get interesting if they sense that in a
week one
see week two week three week four I have
a hard time believing that and I'm not
trying a sense perception reality - yeah
I get you exactly when everyone's
talking about this is a player you start
looking for anything man to make you
think whether or not yeah I'm right they
are it doesn't look like they're
rebuilding you're right
but I will say this I know some of those
guys down there Brian Flores Chad O'Shea
they're tough hard-nosed guys it's good
they're gonna grind it out they just got
to kind of find their way and they'll
find a way to be a little more
competitor than they were on this the
Sunday
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports